so I'm Monica Kulkarni I'm the CEO of a
company called crowd buttocks we are a
company that uses accommodations of
crowds and machine learning to build
software faster in ways that we think
will be interesting
prior to this I ran a company for many
years called lead genius which was a
private verticalized crowdsourcing
platform before that I was at Berkeley
so a little bit about how I got into
this space started a company called lead
genius when I was in grad school with
three other PhD students at the time
lead genius was a private crowd labor
engine so by crowd labor I'm referring
to systems that are like Mechanical Turk
or up work but this was private meaning
that you couldn't sign up and post any
kind of work you wanted to you could
only do one kind of work
it's used by non-specialists so you
didn't know that you were using crowds
when you used it you actually thought
you were buying a sales product but
behind the scenes everything that was
happening was crowdsourcing we were
venture backed we raised about 20
million dollars in venture funding
company is still going strong employs
about 50 people in downtown Berkeley
still close to home it also employs
about 500 people worldwide which was an
interesting goal of the company to try
and create employment a large scale and
attack poverty through crowdsourcing and
we're still successful at doing that we
pay about four million dollars out of
year to base and middle income
communities around the world started a
company called crowd bollocks late last
year to apply some of the same ideas to
software engineering I also do research
and both these companies are spin out to
the research that I've done in
crowdsourcing I'm interested in two
questions the first is how we can build
crowd platforms that are fairer that try
and create more equitable relationships
between people who are doing the work
and people who need the work done how
you can use them to address issues
around unemployment or income inequality
and then also in this question of how
you can create more complex things
artifacts outcomes as a result of crowd
work
okay so what does crab computer
hopefully some folks have an idea and I
won't do it okay well then to you guys
you figure it out more structure on the
process yeah that's a terrific
definition informally
I sometimes characterize it as how do we
get groups of strangers to do stuff that
we want them to do over the internet but
I think the remit has actually been
transformed recently and it goes into a
much more expansive view in the way that
you're describing so Rob Miller at MIT
used to talk about this definition of
crowd computing is how do you get people
and computers to work together to
achieve things that neither one can do
on their own but the modern definition
that I like is I got this from Walter
Lacetti at University of Michigan which
is computational management science how
do you program teams of people to do
things that are cool interesting hard
difficult and that covers a pretty big
spectrum of things so some examples of
this that we may or may not recognize
this crowd work at first glance you have
systems that are a true virtual labor
things like fiber which is a simple
platform to pay people a small amount of
money to do a thing for you you have up
work which used to be oDesk which is a
system for hiring people over the web to
do freelance work and then you have
pieces of work that are really small
micro tasks platforms like Mechanical
Turk and these are systems that are
software where software assigns the work
to be done
they're done virtually and people will
actually carry them out online so they
send you work digitally and responds
then you've got systems that are
coordinating groups of people in the
real world where they're physically
executed but the algorithm is dictating
who is going to do what so uber and lyft
are favorite examples because you have
lots of crowd workers who are showing up
and doing things on demand and there's
software layers that are mediating the
relationship between the requester of
work and the executor of work but that
also includes systems like instacart or
TaskRabbit where people are being
dispatched out for gigs by a software
system the other end of the spectrum
that I think is starting to get eaten
starting to be eaten by crowd work is
this idea of non software contract works
you can imagine hiring a freelance
writer or a freelance consultant or
maybe just getting somebody to work for
you for a few hours as a favor that's
also a form of crowd work and we don't
always recognize recognize it as such if
you have a job inside an organization so
that's schedule my work for Jimmy fast
they should i think i think that there's
a there is a process we're seeing here
where crowd work is getting consumed or
what we might think of as as traditional
work is being eaten away as more and
more computational processes get
involved in our day to day jobs those
start to look more like large-scale
crowd work but the strong relationship
that you have with your employer is
usually what differentiates it so this
is the trend that I'm that that I'm
alluding to the technology mediated
crowd labor is starting to eat away at
conventional employment in lots of ways
according to Pew about a third of
Americans maybe less depending on how
you define crowd work worked in the gig
economy in some form last year so
there's a feeling that combined with
automation this is going to affect
conventional employment in some ways
even expert jobs are probably going to
be affected we have seen a trend in the
crowd research community where
tasks that we thought that could only be
done by an expert can be done by teams
of people plus some software who are not
experts so this is something that we
have to watch and think about in the
research community we've seen an
interesting trend and crowd research in
the last few years back when we started
ten years ago as a crowd research
community we thought about crowd work as
micro work stuff you do on Amazon
Mechanical Turk or games of the purpose
really tiny tasks right things like
reCAPTCHA
Bilu Ivana at Carnegie Mellon where you
do something that was really really
short you'd have a lot of people do it
and you could parallel eyes work in a
very big way recently we've got stuff
that's about five years ago where people
were interested in chaining together
micro tasks in interesting ways to
design workflows things that were taking
complex activities and breaking them out
into sequences of chain tasks nowadays
last couple of years we've seen good
work some of it at Stanford some of it
elsewhere looking at how you can think
about grad work as programmatic
collaborations for complex tasks things
like producing a video producing a
software interface using teams and
interesting ways so this trend of
increase in complexity is showing where
we're going as a crowd research
community but it's also being reflected
by the kinds of things we're seeing on
the industry side which is where I spend
most of my time so ten years ago you had
a bunch of these platforms that were
basically open-ended labor platforms
that were handling simple micro tasks
Mechanical Turk oDesk Elance freelancer
CrowdFlower
they were all built for simple work back
then five years ago you had companies
and merge that took advantage of these
workflows to productize a sequence of
human activities with some software
layers on top that made it look like it
wasn't a crowd that was doing the work
and allowed people to buy it and use it
really easily so three examples or
captricity which was also a berkeley
spin-out which allows you to use
Mechanical Turk without knowing using
Mechanical Turk to digitize lots of
documents rain forest QA which I'll talk
about
a little bit using the chemical circuit
large-scale to automate software testing
and lead genius did this for sales and
marketing recently we're seeing a new
trend the kinds of companies that are
being formed nowadays around crowd work
look more like the kind of research
projects that people are trying to come
up with on the academic side where
people are coming up with complex
software systems that are mediating with
each other - or that are mediating the
relationship between buyers and sellers
of work in advanced way so b12 is a good
example which is working on trying to
crowdsource the software design process
systems like Angel list or modifying the
transactions that happen between groups
of very specialized crowds investors and
companies and then crab products is
thinking about this in software
development okay so today I'm going to
think talk about three things and so we
have a little time for discussion I'll
make sure that those that the
discussions here are short on each one
of these so first I'll give you a little
retrospective on lead genius which was
the large-scale verticalized crowd
platform that we built tell you a little
bit about how we developed that then
we'll jump into crowd dot X which is our
project today to write software with
crowds and last I'll close with some big
open challenges that I think are
interesting for us to look at as a
research community okay so we'll start
with Lee genius and its previous form
was a system called mobile works so 2012
along with Bjorn Hartman and tap per
week at Berkeley my co-founders and I
started a company called mobile works we
were a non marketplace architecture for
accurate human computation if you look
at that title you can see the kinds of
things that we cared about as crowd
researchers back in 2012 which was
accuracy and how you could avoid
marketplace dynamics and the negative
repercussions of those dynamics if
you've used Mechanical Turk you may have
you may remember a time when the biggest
challenge was quality and back then we
used to think about crowds in a way that
is not very popular today thanks to the
work of many people in the crowd
research community we should
think of the crowd is basically bandits
who are out to trick us right these are
these are these folks who are showing up
we don't know they are on a crowd
research platform they're anonymous
they're transient they show up they take
our money they disappear they don't have
much skill they don't have much
engagement and a lot of the systems that
we built back then were designed to try
and combat those trends to try and make
sure the people were forced to be honest
or forced to they were prevented from
cheating us in some ways so we we
rejected that view as part of the thesis
for building our crowd platform we have
this idea that you could get better
results from a crowd marketplace by
setting up a system where you treated
workers like real people who were coming
back over and over again driving
engagement over time and trying to
recognize them as humans which of course
is a very natural approach if if you
come from that universe you think about
earlier the returning repeatedly sounds
more and more like a traditional
relationship so that's a great question
so in fact if I had to give a critique
looking back on what we were doing in in
lead genius and mobile works I think a
lot of the choices that we made and the
reason we got good results in working
with our crowd was that we adopted many
of the paradigms of a traditional
organization and you'll see that you
know we we did many of the same things
that incur a lot of overhead in a real
organization like having management
structures in place like having
performance reviews like having peer
relationships we did do those things via
software and as opposed to doing them
via informal mechanisms or social social
conventions but I think we adopted some
of the best practices from real world
organizations that made us less like a
crowdsourcing flat marketplace it's also
why it worked yeah so
I had to expand on this we talked about
this idea as good work that treating
workers fairly would lead to
quantifiably better outcomes I think a
corollary on that based on your point
Michael is that treating workers like
they are treated in a real-world
organization leads crowd workers to
behave better and yield better results
so there were some insights in there
that were useful we have the best
workers in the crowd become managers
they would supervise and teach the rest
of the crowd so it stopped becoming a
totally flat marketplace very quickly we
would actively assign tasks to members
of the crowds we wouldn't actually treat
it a total totally as a marketplace we
would make sure work got done because
we'd pick out who should get the work
and say you're doing this job today we
priced automatically we set a price
floor in the system where you said
everyone gets a minimum wage and that
made our workers very happy
so that management model looks much more
like a real-world organization the
people who are working for the crowd
were divided into teams
they had teams of two or three at the
bottom who rolled up two team leads who
rolled up themselves two managers rolled
up with super managers and at the end of
the day everyone reported up to one
person in our office who was managing a
giant crowd of lots and lots of people
it was not me yes and that was by design
as well we actually had specialized
roles that developed over time as well
people who were QA people who were
interviewers who were just tasked with
evaluating other members of the crowd
people who were HR and tasked with
determining if people were meeting their
metrics or not and I think many of these
roles could have been done software we
just chose not to and we had this nice
system that we had built for managing
all this via a software model so we had
a virtual office where people were
continuously chatting with each other
looking at the performance that our
system assigned to them and it allowed
the crowd to interface with each other
in terms of supervising hiring firing
things like that so one of the cool
activities that we did here that was
extremely effective and far more
effective than I would have predicted
was to
simply put workers into a pure
relationship with each other where they
could chat and talk about the work they
were doing historically in micro work
there was an attitude that you should
try and keep workers separate and part
of that was forced by the dynamics of
the Mechanical Turk marketplace where
workers would experience the system in
isolation here workers were permanently
put into persistent chat where they
would discuss with their teams or with
their colleagues different projects they
were working on which allowed us to do a
lot of quality control before we even
had to get to a sophomore question so
you can see here two examples of
situations where workers were either
talking to a superior worker somebody
who had been given status in the system
to diagnose a question or situation
where somebody had an issue with an
actual project they were working on they
didn't know the answer to and somebody
else is able to address it and you can
see here also that this allowed us to do
things that we didn't expect there's a
conversation happening here in Russian
and nobody in our organization spoke
Russian but we were able to successfully
carry out the work and recruit a fairly
large russian-speaking community that
was required for this project because we
had peer support systems in place so
everybody in these chat threads is a
member of the crowd as opposed to
somebody was working for the company and
a firm in relationship and actually this
model had a bunch of positive side
effects ooh right like late last year
two of our workers got married to each
other one was in the Philippines and one
was in Serbia so a very long distance
relationship muted entirely over that
chat interface which was an interesting
dynamic and there's been some some great
research done by Mary Grey and Sid Suri
at Microsoft looking at the lead genius
community in particular as well as a few
others if you're interested in some of
these dynamics I hadn't heard you to
read it because she spent a lot of time
with both our community of workers and a
few others to figure out what was
working and what wasn't so it was very
interesting because we had to walk a
fine line at times between tweeting
the community as an online community
which was not officially part of the
company sums that they were medium
engagement users of our product and
people who were doing work through our
system for our customers and balancing
that line it required us to do do a few
things so a lot of the support and the
grievances and the resolution of the
problems that were experienced happy be
pushed back to the community and saying
okay you guys are gonna figure out ways
to resolve these here's resources that
we recommend you use to resolve these
issues harassment did come up at times
and we saw situations where people were
sometimes bad actors we worked out ways
to expeditiously remove those
individuals before they got into the
system and we got pretty good at later
on there was a complex interview process
that will get to where we got to screen
through a bunch of people very quickly
so just to sum up on this point mobile
works like lead mobile works and lead
genius basically we're on the other end
they were what we call a man managed
crowd they were on the opposite end of
where we thought we would end up which
was in microwork per task pay and so on
so we did work on this question as well
which is worth mentioning which is how
you can get people to escape poverty or
improve their standard of living using
crowd work we didn't have an hourly wage
that was supported by the World Bank we
pulled people from historically
underrepresented or underemployed
communities and we tried to work on
productivity measurements that would
keep people honest during that model
tended to work out okay okay so how do
we find good workers so we basically had
three approaches first one was a web
search people would just discover us on
the web that worked okay we got much
better workers by just asking the crowd
to recruit other members of the crowd
join turned out to be phenomenally
effective and we'd pay them bonuses and
treat it like any other task in the
system which was cool we also worked
with a bunch of nonprofits and
government agencies who wanted to get
employment for their communities so went
up to Jamaica with the World Bank to
and talk about how crowd work is an
interesting way to find economic
opportunities I still think that crowd
work is a great economic enabler in many
parts of the world you can see there's
another one of our teams and the
Philippines looking very happy because
they worked for us okay so once we had
this stream of people coming in we
basically put them through a three-part
test they'd actually carry out a small
task information retrieval usually so we
could verify that they were able to read
interpret instructions respond to them
we'd give them a right have them do a
writing sample like a situational
challenge we'd have them do an audio
sample another situational challenge and
then if they got through all of that so
here's an example right of the the
actual lead genius test they were given
questions with grammatical errors in
them and they have to find the error and
fix it so all this was automated and it
made sure that we could actually get
people who could follow and interpret
instructions really well and we got to
about an 8% accept rate for people who
tried to take this test so it was a
pretty broad stream of people we would
filter through to get our actual workers
the final step would be an actual human
review of that person and we didn't
interview them ourselves we had somebody
in the crowd who was known to be good
interview those people and that allowed
us to maintain a pretty high level of
quality going forward and of course
after they were hired the software would
monitor them their peers amount of them
and so on and would look something like
this you'd have a nice pretty stream of
various activities and reviews that they
had done over the course of some time in
addition to 8% we also had about 1% of
the community who we'd fire every month
it was unvoluntary usually not people
who said ham I'm leaving I don't like
this anymore but people would say you're
not meeting the criteria we're gonna
filter you out okay so I'll tell you a
really short story about how we went
from this open-ended crowd platform and
to lead genius we started out thinking
we would replace Mechanical Turk we were
wrong Mechanical Turk was not nearly as
big as we thought it would be
we did a lot better just by going from
trying to compete with Amazon Mechanical
Turk small five million dollar market
size in 2011 to a product called lead
genius which basically took that crowd
that we had built that was highly
effective and carefully screened and
turned them into a lead generation
engine what that means is we would carry
out this one particular task which if
you follow the crowd literature
sometimes called crowd DB which means
somebody asks you for some large-scale
amount of information that doesn't exist
in any one database you look through a
lot of different databases to finish
that query so for example if you're a
salesperson you might come to lead
genius and say give me every company in
Brazil that purchased online ads in 2014
and find out the director of marketing
of each of those companies it's a pretty
complex query it's got multiple pieces
of information that are stored in
different systems all over the web all
over public databases private databases
government records and so on you can use
crowds very effectively to stitch that
information together especially if you
have crawlers that are pulling out
information from sources all the time so
that was lead genius you know where we
ended up in a nutshell and that's how we
got this thing to scale up super fast we
generated tons of work just around this
kind of activity sales people would use
it they wouldn't need to know anything
about crowdsourcing they wouldn't need
to know anything about our beautiful
model for work or treatment and this
allowed us to generate lots and lots of
work and the product is great if you are
a salesperson and still use it and
basically the idea here was the trend
that we're talking about we took a
project that historically had been done
just by a person as a low-level
salesperson inside an office and
combined it with crowds and software to
basically take it off of people's plates
so there's a role inside sales
organizations called sales development
representatives and historically their
time had been spent looking people up on
LinkedIn right or cold calling people
which is a not very effective use of
somebody's day we basically replace that
with a productized crowdsourcing flow
called lead genius which allowed them to
focus on higher value activities didn't
mean that you'd put everybody out of
work who was a sales development wrap it
meant that they
just spend a lot less of their time
digging up information yeah that led to
a steady supply of work from people who
didn't need to know what crowdsourcing
was so it worked pretty well for the
actual goal of lead genius that we
started with which was not to build a
sales product but rather to figure out
ways to generate employment for a bunch
of people who were in a crowd that's our
worker monthly worker
excuse me quarterly worker payout for
the last four years and it's getting up
there right we we do about four million
a year right now I think and work abouts
maybe a little little more now we had
great results in terms of the social
dynamics on all of our social impact
studies we were trying to ask if we
could actually impact people's lives
generally our survey said yes although
these weren't scientifically great
because we ran these sort of internally
about 70% of our community didn't have a
job before they found us 85% of them
were supporting one or more children so
this was basically supporting families
and about 10% of them were single
mothers and today we're paying at about
four million dollars a year did a bunch
of surveys got a bunch of fan mail too
we bundled a lot of this into a movement
we started last year with shot
the National Domestic Workers Alliance
which was this thing called the good
work code we tried to rally a bunch of
crowd labor platforms and crowd labor
users to commit to doing honest fair
treatment of their communities and it's
gotten some momentum behind it so
there's been a bunch of signatory so far
although of course we don't have
Mechanical Turk or the big guys for
being gay
yeah so we actually thought about this
question a whole bunch cuz we in the
beginning thought that this would be a
great trajectory and a great outcome
that we would graduate people into the
traditional economy unfortunately
there's a perverse incentive for crowd
labor companies once you've trained
somebody to be really good you don't
want them to leave you want them to keep
working for you and it wasn't actually a
an effective outcome for them if they
went and joined some other company so so
we didn't track this data so I don't
have information about that we did track
a different system a different metric
which for us was internal mobility we
would promote people inside the company
from being a junior team member to a
senior product manager or seizure senior
project manager and we actually some
people were so good we hired them in our
office in our core team not a lot of
them but many of them made made that
trajectory so that was interesting to
see since I'm curious if you have any
data on is what the upward mobility
opportunities were within your company
versus the ones that would have been
surrounding them had they left the
company for example if they got promoted
within your company or the opportunities
they're simply better because you were
willing to come into this good work code
than anything that I could have gotten
outside yeah that's a really interesting
question so part of our market strategy
was targeting communities where people
did not have good employment
opportunities based on their current
skill set in their community so a good
example would be we worked with a number
of woman Muslim women in very
conservative communities where they were
not encouraged to leave the home for
work they were fantastic for us because
they didn't have alternative
opportunities and they were able to
develop quite a strong reputation inside
our community that couldn't be exported
outside for reasons that were outside of
our control I suspect that if you wanted
to build a model like this that was
large-scale enough to and your goal was
to try and transition people off of your
system you could do that it would be an
interesting question to ask you know how
do you link them up with with the just
enough skills
they're useful and you can push them out
to somewhere else generate leads for
them to pursue get jobs actually you
certainly could yes that was that was
all the time okay it's a fantastic
question so one of the dynamics we had
one of the design decisions we had to
make early on was the question of the
level of engagement we would expect from
the community because as you know you've
got on crowd platforms folks who are
treating it more like a steady a
full-time employment where they're
committing 8it hours a day or more and
you've got a large community of folks
who are just freelancing part-time for
fun who are carrying at unstructured
tasks the latter community is really
useful for a crowd platform because they
introduce liquidity they show up
whenever you want and they go away quite
happily they are not great if you're
trying to build an organization over
time and it's because they're unreliable
they disappear so you know in a perfect
universe everybody is a full-time
manager right or willing to work like a
full-time manager and nobody is sleeping
in and showing up doing a few things and
disappearing so we ended up biasing our
system in the same way to prefer that
model so in our model everybody was
acting like a manager in the sense that
we would require them to work a minimum
of 20 hours a week if they wanted to
join the system and we simply we had
enough inbound interest that we would be
able to maintain enough of a community
even just taking people who had 20 hours
a week or availability
the overwhelming majority of folks
preferred to work 30 or 40 hours a week
I will say that that time was somewhat
unstructured so they didn't have to do
it all at a given time if they wanted to
cool so I won't go too much into the
good work code you can read about it
online if you want there's also the
future of crowd work paper which talks
about more or less the same issues how
you can make fab platforms that are
ethical that are fair that are honest
and so on that treat workers fairly we
rated our community rated us on these
different dimensions along the good work
code there was some that we were
exceptional on there were some where we
need to do some more work so these kinds
of surveys on crowd platforms I hope
become more common so that people who
are designing platforms will think about
the design directions they need to
improve on so that's how we use this
data we basically use that to decide
where we should focus our development
efforts to try and improve our system
and here's some here's a sample of this
data right people we asked about pay
rates a lot because this was a question
we scrapped 'old with mightily at the
beginning how much do you pay people for
a given piece of work we looked at World
Bank survey as we looked at published
rates for poverty data and okay most
people thought their work was fair but
everyone wants to earn a little bit more
and that's an area that we I think could
do some more thinking on but of course
we got a lot of fan mail - that's fan
mail from one of our workers they
thought this was better than a job cycle
even though they were being a freelancer
and you know working online they
actually thought this was worth worth
doing we did have good cases of people
who actually use this to basically
guarantee income security and a lot of
people reinvested in their families so
there was some feel-good stories in
there which was nice
those are all community members by the
way great so next up I'll talk about the
new company robotics which is answering
this question how you can write software
with crowds I want to leave some time
for discussion
so I'll be direct on on going through
this right so the motivation for this
company was that a couple years ago at
lead genius we started seeing this funny
thing happening with this community that
we would build to people who were doing
effectively online database research for
us we'd built this interface to put data
in which was basically a form and our
community would use that all day to
enter data about companies but they
didn't use that they actually ended up
using this interface which we hadn't
built this was VOC this sort of showed
up in the wild and we were really
confused that this thing had emerged
before what we thought was a pretty
specialized task on a private platform
somebody you know that somehow somebody
had come up with another another
interface that was arguably better than
ours and a lot of ways same thing
happened with our database research tool
that we had built we had an internal
database of lots of companies you could
research it people didn't use it they
instead we're using a custom Google
interface that somebody had put together
okay so this was really surprising
because you know we had at the core
engineering team who had been building
product for a long time and we spent a
lot of time building this stuff out and
people were just sort of showing up with
these tools in the wild that we're
making their lives better so we found
through what was happening what turned
out what it turned out was that people
who were in this community in our crowd
happened to know how to program and they
just built their own interfaces for
trying to make their jobs easier we
didn't ask them to do it they just
showed up and did it this was really a
surprising turn of events for us because
we had a community here that was
basically earning enough money to
provide income security they were doing
work that was not designed to be highly
skilled or specialized but they were
able to do work that we considered very
specialized which was software
development so he's the two people who
actually built those two interfaces in
particular we went and tracked them down
to find out what was happening one was a
computer science student in Kingston
Jamaica one was a mother living in
Colorado and they were they both told us
the same thing which was that they were
ambitious they wanted to learn more
about technology
sometimes they had technology experience
or programming experience but they
couldn't get job opportunities to be a
software developer in the communities
they lived and there just weren't enough
opportunities for people with that level
of skill and so you could probably I'd
speculate that you could probably say
something like this that for any big
enough community you look at some one
portion of those are gonna be experts in
something especially software
development ok so we built this model
which actually worked out which was we
took developers we took those folks and
said instead of working for $5 an hour
entering data about leads why don't you
just work with us on software
development we'll pair you up with one
of our software engineers in-house you
guys will work together and we'll see
what will happen so before we get into
crab but I'll tell you what happens what
happened here for us and we'll skip over
the sort of the the long story here and
tell you about how it worked for us
okay so mmm
skipping into this okay so we basically
tried to things that lead genius right
one was this idea that we would have the
crowd
design and build their own stuff
completely from scratch right so we said
hey we're having you guys do this
activity which is entering leads and you
guys see the interface that we've got
you know how our system works come up
with your own ideas for how you're going
to build these tools and give them out
to us like we'll look at what you've
come up with we'll give it a fair shot
and we will decide if it's if we like it
enough to to actually use it so we
didn't give them access to any of our
internal systems we didn't try to teach
them how to write code or tell them what
we wanted in that first approach we just
let them do whatever they wanted and
said we're gonna take a look open call
for contributions right in the second
approach we actually invited people to
install a copy of our code so they this
was like a would have been a big
security breach if it didn't think of
big company but we said let's see what
happens
we open mirror our entire code base
twain with our one of our engineers and
actually work on making contributions
via get
so they would actually try to write code
that we would ask them to write out and
so this was a one-to-one matching model
right we'd have an apprentice in the
community and we'd have a an engineer in
house and they would work together to
build code okay so start out with these
two experts we use those experts to find
more experts we used a technique that
was called the crowd search which was in
a 2014 age comp paper called wish which
you can look at if you want to learn
about that algorithm and how it worked
the short answer is basically you have
experts ask around to find other experts
that's the sort of the tiny tiny example
of how it works we did get a bunch of
other experts we found people who had
you know built stuff like this in the
past some of this is material that we
wouldn't consider a particularly good
design but the code was clean and the
experts attested to the code being clean
so we said great you guys are going to
be the experimental community for this
we found six people plus those two so we
did this experiment with eight people
back in 2015 we tried the tomb of these
two models with this small community of
folks
okay so first strategy was open call for
contributions just with the incentive of
people improving the work platform
didn't give them any specific directions
just that what can you come up with okay
so this actually worked that was kind of
interesting people did not do this for
the money they we didn't actually offer
them specific pay for it we just told
them that we'd give out their code to
other people if we liked it people
contributed projects in angular
JavaScript and also reconfigured public
interfaces on other tools to make them
more more usable all eight of those
folks came up with new ideas that was
that we're interesting we probably don't
think that's not surprising because
expert crowd users should be able to
come up with new ideas for how to
improve a system they proposed three
kinds of things workflows improvements
two specific features and ideas for new
features some of those were actually
useful some were less useful
the crowd was much better at doing this
when they had more experience in a given
interface for product they also tested
this stuff a lot more than we did with
the community which was something that
was interesting so if it was a project
of the crowd had actually been working
on a member of the crowd had been
working on in the past they actually had
better insights and they were more
willing to shop that their own the
actual users of the system than we were
and that's because they were embedded
with that community every day ok so this
was actually interesting for us we
tutored is basically a rapid prototyping
tool we did not use their code out of
the box
we ended up rewriting at all if we like
the actual results then we just rebuilt
it from scratch and we built a Chrome
extension this way and a few other tools
and this was pretty effective it could
work for target problems but it was
mostly just an efficiency gain for us we
needed new ideas we asked for an open
call for new ideas and expert engineers
could come up with it so that's cool ok
the next model we tried was centrally
directed contributions and this model
was very interesting because it's much
more like the model that we ultimately
ended up using so in this one we
actually took members of the crowd we
paired them up with individual engineers
in the team and we said you're gonna be
a mentor to this person and you're
responsible for their performance so
they would communicate over email over
HipChat
and over github comments these folks had
system access they were basically like
interns joining the team temporarily
except they had been pulled out of the
crowd using this search model ok so we
actually tasked them with specific
issues and github so we'd say here's the
one you're gonna own go do it they'd get
notified go write the code submit a pull
request to us we could have been more
sophisticated here we weren't because we
were just part of typing this thing out
to see how it go then the developer
in-house would actually review the
results and commit it back in okay so
successes first time we tried this a
great thing was we got a lot of code
committed and a lot of code built
okay so that was the upside of this
intuitive approach in fact we got 20
commits out of those crowd numbers into
production code so each of those folks
contributed one or two things on average
into our code base they were highly
motivated so we asked about skills
skills trajectories inside organizations
people who were doing this we're working
in some cases for the first time as
professional software engineers at any
capacity and somebody was giving them a
shot for the first time so they liked
that and they liked that a lot more than
they did doing low-level crowd work they
also had unique insights the same kind
of insights that they had we saw in the
open call model as users the system
there were also big downsides to this
this very naive approach oh sorry I'll
just show you one example here's
something that somebody built you can
see that as a QA Status model right
there that drop down was entirely built
by a crowd worker so not a particularly
fancy feature not something too advanced
but something simple and well defined
that somebody can construct in the
course of a single pull request okay but
this approach is prone to a lot of
failures and if you've worked with
interns before you probably can guess
what some of those are the first one was
that even though we had screen people
for the expert for their expertise and
being able to write good code there are
a lot of dynamics that occur during
software development that have nothing
to do with your ability to write code
and have a lot more to do with your
ability to communicate effectively to
task out or predict the difficulty of
tasks and to collaborate directly with
another developer or a product manager
or a designer
none of these were things that in our
initial approach we had actually tested
for screen for and of course the
engineers who were actually working with
these developers didn't know exactly how
they should be managing an intern and so
there were a lot of examples of places
where the net time that was taken was
not a creative but it was detrimental
the two folks working together spent
more time than just the engineer having
done the work themselves
so there were also issues of course
where the pull requests were not
accepted people would make the code
requests and the engineer would say it
was it's not a priority we're gonna look
at this some other time when I finished
my own work so these are things that at
least with this naive approach we
encountered in not surprising ways some
more surprising outcomes where that code
crowd experts would work too much this
was the first time they've done any sort
of soften did any worse they didn't want
to let go of it and we saw a couple
cases where people would just work 60
hours 80 hours trying to you know do a
really good job but that's not really an
effective way to to build a good product
we also had complaints about people not
following code Styles complaints about
people who were not necessarily
following conventions even if they were
writing code that was technically
correct
they wouldn't adapt to the natural code
style of company or things like that so
it was not too different from what you
might get from hiring a brand new junior
engineer straight out of school and in
retrospect that's not terribly
surprising so this was effective once we
had gotten past that initial onboarding
phase so once we had ramp the coder
once we corrected them on a few tough
you instances of coding style
communication style we got this model to
actually work it was efficient
eventually efficient so we carried out a
series of tasks to measure what the
joint output looked like the first time
we did this it was not a creative at all
by the time we figured out the model and
we had folks working together in sync
the combined team of senior developer
plus junior assistant got about 1.5 X
the output of a single engineer so that
was pretty good
that's took a little bit of heavy
lifting on our part to try and train
people but that dynamic I suspect could
be implemented in a more efficient way
ok so some big challenges that I think
will be resolved in the near future or
should be resolved for the near future
first one is security and onboarding how
do you share data sets with crowd
workers like this we had ways around
this by creating limited data sets that
simulated the sensitive data that we
wanted to hand out I think if you wanted
to do this in a larger organization it
would be a little trickier and there's a
question of how you'd protect against
this crowd workers were sometimes less
flexible than we wanted them to be or
more flexible than we wanted them to be
in terms of trying to put them into a
streamlined production flow so we'd have
schedules ship dates road maps crowd
workers could be assigned stuff from
those items but if it was critical path
and the crowd worker decided to take a
day off well that would have interfered
with our business so understanding how
to remediate that's another interesting
open question we saw an interesting
trend where people didn't follow the
roadmap they'd pick up something I
thought was more interesting so that was
something that will likely need to we
would need to address but of course it
was interesting that we could actually
crowdsource contributions through
crowdsourcing platform right
we found that crowd members could
contribute usefully to production code
in a crowd system and as long as you're
careful about product management and you
have good communication you can make
this work and that close support that
you get is pretty similar to what you
need from an in-house employee one thing
that we did add into the system
eventually was redundancy so if people
could not do the work themselves
somebody else would show up and get the
work done that made this model more or
less workable in a production setting so
that was work we did in 2015 and 2016
since then we spun out a company based
just on this idea which is crowd
bollocks so we do and we pay them more
than other crowd workers so to give you
a sense of what the numbers look like
when we were doing this at lead genius
at lead genius our average worker would
earn and they were not in the u.s. about
four dollars and fifty cents per hour
with all the things it was all depended
on the country they were in and their
seniority within our system if they were
a developer in our system we would pay
them $10 per hour and looking at global
wages for software development I don't
think that we're too far off in a lot of
geographies at that wage in terms of
getting somebody who's good
so what crowd BOTS X we've looked at
this question specifically around how
much you should earn as a software
developer living in various geographies
and to some extent it matters a lot less
because you are selling to customers in
the US where software development
services are at a premium
but in geographies like Kenya or Lima
Peru earning between 10 and 20 dollars
an hour is a reasonable freelancing rate
for a software developer experience for
the worker of being very good later it's
like getting almost a mentoring
relationship with a cog in a machine
versus having some relationships so so
we've seen this a little bit in we saw
this a little bit of lead genius we see
it much more now kradic's because we
think just about the developer question
that lead genius people just wanted a
shot at getting a chance to be a
professional coder in some respect they
didn't necessarily know that mentorship
or the the experience of working in the
team would be the big value that crowd
dot X when we talked to our community
today we hear very very commonly that
the interest is in working with an
interesting team of people to develop
some set of skills and to get experience
and exposure different styles of
building software which is something
that they find appealing we also play
some tricks which we can talk about in
the discussion around providing new
opportunities for people to promote
the ideas that they're learning with us
in their communities so I'll give you
the punchline on crab bollocks so this
model worked well enough at lead genius
that we spend out as a new company we
ended up building a whole new platform
based on work we've done after that
point we figured out ways to find and
curate communities of coders to figure
out how to get these guys to collaborate
via software and to help us write
software so crab products as a company
exists right now to use crowdsourcing to
build software the model works I'll show
you some examples basically the idea is
that we spin up instances of slack and
integrate with github directly using up
work behind the scenes to track time
management to deploy software engineers
really quickly into saw into new
organizations so the model that we use
today at kradic's is a master apprentice
model that model turned out to be the
best and most effective customers
appoint a product owner or a product
master inside the teams they get a bunch
of developers who show up to work for
them and then they can add one to for
developers per engineer they've gotten
their team so it's sort of this
acceleration framework they can build
code a lot faster and it's live it
actually works pretty well
developers are pretty good and pretty
cheap the reason they're pretty cheap is
that we're sourcing from geographies
that are typically low cost of living
number is is the low end of what we end
up charging sometimes customers end up
paying up to 50 or $100 an hour
depending on the skill the worker and
depending on where the developer is
actually based and all the communication
we do today is either via the product
via slack or via github I'll show you
some examples of the actual transitions
that are actually produced so here you
can see this is the kind of interactions
that our customers have I'll give you a
couple more examples developer will
implement something based on a design
shown by somebody else so at the left
you're seeing there a sample of a task
somebody gave to the system where they
said here's an interface I like can you
reproduce this for me
and there at the right you see that
there is a interface that was produced
in the course of about four hours with
the same interactions in place there are
some differences of course and I can
talk about why those differences emerge
and how you can remediate that but
they're not super difficult to eliminate
and then here's behind the scenes what
the process looks like so here you can
see what a developer actually produced
while they were actually constructing
this so this is an action plan that was
designed by the crowd developer based on
the task that was given to them and this
was not guided by software this was
guided by the developers own planning
process and the templatized structure
that we impose on the system so there's
steps in here
that the developer had to think through
herself in this case so you know looking
at the assets trying to reproduce them
pushing your code to github and so on
well so I'll give you I guess two
answers right to the extent that we are
creating value for our customers it's
okay if we get this remediated right
because if we found a great developer
and that developer is a great match for
the organization fantastic the customer
pays us a small fee and then they go and
get to keep the developer forever but in
the short term in the medium term we
have to eliminate that through software
so right now we have a strong software
interface that allows us to control that
relationship in a way that is difficult
to eliminate in particular a lot of the
planning activities here that you're
seeing are things that we want to impose
into the structure the system itself and
you know our margins but is not that
gigantic in every case and so in many
cases the the value is bigger I'm in
maintaining the relationship with us
there was a discussion at lunch that's
also relevant to this which is we're a
risk buffer and a trust buffer which is
important for the
things that we work with and for the
developers we work with so here you can
see typical Sprint board that's being
produced by developer while they're
doing work like this okay good so I'll
close
I think we've a couple minutes left and
we can jump to some discussion so I'll
close with a couple of open problems
that I think are fun first one is code
security so if you're looking at this
question of how do you crowdsource
software development one of the big
questions is how do you securely share
code how do you make for the people who
are getting it have very limited access
and are seeing just the pieces that you
want so today we solve it in a way that
is not software oriented we basically
screen our developers exceptionally
thoroughly and make sure that they're
very honest people and we sign very
strong ironclad relationships with them
that also reduces the risk of distant
disintermediation but it would be much
cleaner to have a software solution for
this where we were virtualizing
somebody's code base and then
selectively exposing just the code that
somebody needed to work on so we can
operate with a much lower trust model
haven't done that yet but I think it's
an interesting technical question second
one is around task assignment so you saw
a structure here where we basically
allowed developers to plan out the
entirety of their day I'd love to get a
model where we can actually have people
who are less technical use the software
that that somebody produces to
appropriately produce a task list all
right so if I show you an interface I'd
love to get a task list like that out
automatically that says here's the
different pieces you need to actually
build a project like this of course the
third one which I think we've talked
about a bunch of times today in the
various meetings and conversations we've
had which is how you can take code off
the web and use them in a process like
this so there's code repositories all
over the the internet that we should be
able to use to drop into this process to
speed things up I think we'll get to an
interesting place by trying to inject
some of that and we'll do some of this
work this summer and there's lots of
interesting hard machine learning
problems there too that are fun cool so
I think with that we'll just wrap things
up we can skip that out and so you guys
will be looking at so you know so that's
that's exactly the solution that we're
thinking about right it's virtualizing
the customers codebase and basically
keeping in a container that we can
create interface with it eliminate it
doesn't solve the problem completely
because somebody could always just read
the code and you know they're learning
something about it but that's where
software plus trust makes it easier or
good enough so how do you do with
creative licensing if from the crowd
someone takes a coat from GPR or LGPL
and concep appache
and they don't copy the header how do
you scan for that that would essentially
jeopardize the entire color yeah so we
haven't implemented this yet but we
thought about this problem right now we
tell people in advance what kinds of
codes we want them to use or not use and
usually there are cases where we we it's
enough to just emphasize that this is
important if you wanted to solve this at
scale we could pass all the code we we
produced through a plagiarism checker
which I think would solve the problem
just check to make sure it's not
matching any of the code from these bad
databases we haven't seen this problem
emerge yet though in a big way and the
reason is that as long as people know
not to use certain licenses for code
most code that's out there is is pretty
good to use for the kinds of work that
we do what's the best how do you measure
the output okay yeah great question so
this was so this was work that we did
as an early experiment and it was a
simple a fairly simple challenge so
maybe not tremendously scientifically
accurate but we basically had a series
of activities like a task list that
somebody had to do with story points
assigned and estimation for each one of
those activities we measured how long it
took an engineer to do it without a
developer we measured how long it took
an engine to do it with a crowd
developer so it's a pretty informal
metric because we had you know one
example of each
but we saw 1.5 X speed up with a trained
person working with a software developer
versus a trained person working by
themselves okay so if you wanted to do
this properly I can point you at papers
in literature that have done this
research this experiment correctly and
they have a good baseline and framework
that can be used for doing experiments
like this those are more customers at
crab products today our tech companies
typical company is fewer than a hundred
people they have a giant product backlog
they need to work a lot faster we were
brought in by the product manager we end
up working with their engineers directly
and people are happy with the fact that
they get product built a lot faster
big companies we haven't shopped to yet
although I think it will it'll be an
interesting angle for us to look at in
the near future so we have seen
variations here it's funny because I
thought in the beginning that the big
use case for this would be sort of small
ongoing intermediate work for example
somebody has a bunch of new interfaces
they want to put up on their product
which does happen and people do like
that kind of flexibility we also saw a
fair number of customers that who just
said great you have developers let me
use them as much as possible and they'll
basically try and maximize usage of the
system so those two categories are the
most common
right that's like like they don't know
what's high-priority even that means
your issue tracker is like not good like
it if they need like to like if they're
writing bad code then like your linters
are like nots limiting polls are not
such good or like that you're going to
tests in like I like your holy document
etc so given that you won't feel like
small small startups which generally
speaking tend to have like worse quality
code is that actually like the rates
match like I would imagine that lately
like large companies that have very good
designs like well I think one way to
think about it is like this to the
extent that we make money has at
kradic's by building software or
building systems for our customers there
is more to be built at a company that
has not yet implemented all of these
rules because we can build those
processes for them as well and
developers one of the nice things that
has emerged from the fact that we are
serving a lot of different clients with
a crowd of developers is that developers
are sharing best practices and imposing
best practices in organizations where
somebody installs crowd bollocks so
somebody might bring in crowd bollocks
for a very small project but realize
based on the recommendations the
developer they've brought in that they
need actually to start doing linting or
improve their test coverage or start
doing better sprint management so in
that sense we're able to help people a
lot more at these small companies which
is which is a nice place to be for us I
think if it works for these communities
it'll easily work in big companies but
the other the converse is not true
you